[Musique]
pour certains cette ville stimulante
incarne le chic et la prospérité
ce n'est que récemment qu'elle est
devenue dangereuse
Jacques je crois que j'ai un sujet trois
femmes ont été étranglées ces deux
dernières semaines
il est hors de question que du coup en
homicide il y a un point commun entre
tous ces meurtres
une autre femme a été étranglée on vient
de la prendre je publie pas la suite non
c'est pas un sujet combien de femmes
doivent mourir avant que ça devienne un
sujet
un faux vérifié pour le quatrième
meurtre la police reste muette je les ai
jamais vues aussi peu loquace
et on l'a tranquillement relâchée
la progression des crimes tout ça si
vous saviez combien de fois j'ai cru
tenir un suspect à chaque fois on se
retrouve dans une impasse
qu'est-ce que tu crois pouvoir trouver
là-bas ça va s'arrêter quand le retard
j'ai besoin que tu me rendes un service
faites vite j'ai aucune envie de me
faire virer
n'importe quel avocat aurait mis le
doigt dessus
tu veux te servir de ce journal pour
démolir nos forces de police si
n'importe qui de l'autre avait fait
preuve d'une telle négligence il y a
bien longtemps qu'il aura fait la Une
j'aurais besoin que tu notes une adresse
si je rappelle pas dans une heure donne
la police Loretta
vous allez nous faire tuer